[Music]
[Applause]
all right I'm scrolling on Twitter and I
just keep seeing this the most
uncomfortable live interview I've ever
watched the cringiest interview the
worst CEO interview I've ever seen and
you know what I got to do you know what
we got to do when it's cringe City cuz
I'm the mayor of cringe City we got to
watch this interview that everybody is
talking about it's the the new CEO of
Twitter so Elon hire this woman Linda
yako she gave an interview and I'm
excited because uh he I love CEO cringe
I love CEO cringe some guys like toes
some people like furries some people
like the Japanese animes [__] they're
into that everybody's got a thing this
is my thing CEO cringe I Can't Get
Enough let's jump
[Applause]
in where am I going I think they're here
yeah for our
microphones yeah maybe go to the empty
chair um Linda thank you for being here
I want to make sure to get uh to give
you an opportunity to respond to yel
Roth and his comments about an hour ago
okay so what happened was at this
conference the code conference and
they've always had a bunch of CEOs come
to this like Steve Jobs Elon Musk uh
Travis colanic from Uber they've had
they always have these Headliners and
this year the headliner was going to be
Linda yako so what I guess what happened
is before she this is she's the
headliner before she went on this guy
yoel Roth who used to work at
Twitter uh was a surprise guest so
that's why this is a little bit
controversial he was a surprise guest
somebody the CEO of GM dropped out they
were like oh we have a last minute
replacement this guy yoel he comes on
and he basically he used to be the head
of trust and safety at Twitter when Elon
first bought it he was like go follow
yel that's the place to get upto-date
info on trust and safety he's the man
and then in five weeks he got fired you
know quit got fired whatever um and him
and Elon got a big spat about it so
they're not on good terms so I guess
this guy yoel came on right before this
and the context is he was obviously
sharing his negativity about Twitter so
she kind of like got like blindsided I
guess before this so that's the
context um Chuckles I'd be happy to
respond um I think I've been given about
45 minutes but I do want to address
um yoel and I don't know each
other he doesn't know me I don't know
him why is she using like a uh Asm R
voice like CEO ASMR she's like it's like
bedtime story as she's like and Hensel
and
gredle went all the way through the
forest is this a funeral why is she
coming out with this energy I've never
seen her talk before so this is uh this
is not what I imagine the CEO of Twitter
or X or whatever to sound like okay more
ASMR I work at X he worked at
Twitter X is a new
company building a foundation based on
free expression and freedom of
speech Twitter at the top ironic by the
way she's like really upset that he just
came on this he went on stage at this
conference and like spoke his mind um
while being like X is the Free Speech
platform shouldn't she just be fine with
him speaking his mind no time was
operating on a different sets of rules
as said by himself uh different uh
philosophies and ideologies that were
creeping down the road of
censorship it's a new day at
X and I'll leave it at
that who else is inspired by that it's a
new day x
and it is what it is like she's trying
to say something
optimistic but the way she's saying it
is this how she always talks the way
she's saying it is so uh downtrodden I
don't understand if you go on stage
everything
is
wonderful we're going
amazing nobody believes you uh so that a
very strange
seriously the uh team at Twitter is
fantastic oh oh right after giving the
big speech that he worked at Twitter I
work at X comes back and says the team
at Twitter is doing
fantastic she's just like all of us we
call it Facebook not better we call it
Twitter not X you can't make fetch a
thing if you're talking about my own
personal well-being and safety uh I feel
great um I'm well protected what I he
made a comment about the Ft interview uh
I guess as he was preparing to come on
the stage uh that the public scrutiny
weighs heavy on me uh my kids my family
my parents uh I think that's just a a
human emotion when you get thrust into
such a public Spotlight uh in
conjunction with the nature of the
platform itself is she is she trying to
hit a word count this is this is me in
ninth grade just double spaced trying to
hit the word count to get to get this in
I mean that's just human nature in
conjunction therefore such as she sounds
like the girl from the the Miss USA
pageant okay people out there in our
nation don't have maps and I believe
that our education like such as in South
Africa and the Iraq everywhere like such
as and S when you're automatically a
recognizable public feature uh public
person 247 globally and and with the
ability for uh or the inability for
anyone to control other
humans uh actions comments recognizable
and I'm an identical twin recognizable
what actions comments recognizable what
what is she talking about think how she
feels all right solid actually made the
security team a a Dollar Bet cuz I only
ever bet a Dollar by the way because the
reason I only bet a dollar let me finish
that for you cuz I'm already
rich the reason I only bet a dollar is
because I'm already super rich and it
would make absolutely no difference to
me if I won or didn't
win you know give it give me the Jeff
Bezos uh laugh it's because I'm super
rich
ever is because it's really only about
winning but I want to uh it's very hard
for me to refute or sift through the
combination of opinions of yoel's
experience and the positioned as fact uh
that were pres she's made two mistakes
so far first ASMR funeral voice telling
the Hansel gr of bedtime story very
strange choice right you come out and
people feel you're making people feel a
certain way because the way it looks
like you feel and so her entire energy
was was wrong she did not come correct
somebody who is confident somebody who
is optimistic about what's going on
somebody who's excited to be here um
they will they would have a totally
different energy so so that was the
first mistake she made was she let this
guy's previous talk throw her completely
off her game and come out with this very
strange energy second thing where now 6
minutes and 30 seconds into this this
interview she still address all the
points that he made nobody would have
even paid attention to that guy's talk
she's six and a half minutes in and is
still playing defense if you're
explaining you're losing right it's as
simple as that like number one PR rule
if you're explaining you're losing and
she is explaining but but Linda because
I I want to shift gears from yoel's
interview to a conversation about the
business nice doing her a solid being
like hey BBE stop talking about y and
start talking about your business y had
25 minutes to talk about it you have a
lot longer yel got the blue one and I
want the blue one but he has the blue
one but then if I get the blue one then
I'm going to have it if if you you want
you have all the time that you have for
us um I want to talk to you about the
business and that and the issues of
Engagement because I see a lot of data
as a reporter at znbc and apptopia which
tracks app usage says the actual time
spent on Twitter did get a post Elon
bump after that acquisition but has
tracked down all year since then a new
report out from apptopia just this month
says app downloads have sunk to new
loads it's in 96th place and when it
comes to usage X is now 25th in active
users behind Telegram and even Samsung
clock so how can we
reconcile what musk has said about
engagement the numbers you just cited
with all of these different data points
here well uh you know with over 54 40
million Global users the I I'd love to
sift through um you know the data points
that that you picked out uh uh and
they're really just tracks tracks of app
downloads and engagement yeah yeah uh
but when you look at the length of time
spent yeah but you know it doesn't yeah
but I don't want to talk about that so
yeah but let's look at something else
the engagement on X right now the key
metrics are trending very very positive
ly so if we want to talk about all the
initiatives that have been put in place
like was covered in the previous
interview about all the uh brand safety
and content moderation tools that exist
now within my first 100 days at the
company that didn't exist for the eight
years prior uh uh formerly known as
Twitter I think those are the type of
things we could be F we should be
focusing on on in terms of progress that
has been made because in the just short
100 days is that I've been at the
company what had to happen was was for
me to you know kind of get in look
on near the
hood why is she acting like a
raccoon get in there sip through the
trash I've seen that I have seen that in
my backyard before that is a Rec go
through trash and when I realized and I
looked at because it's still a lot of
learning what what did you realize Linda
what did you realize say it just say a
simple sentence I mean come on it's it's
100 days there's a lot of learning
that's still going to go on what are the
learning tell me the velocity of change
no we're not talking scope of the
ambition is m
x really say what you Lear does not
exist when you raccooned through the
data what did you find Linda anywhere
else forget the other platforms at any
other company likely on Earth there is
no analog for the book that is being
written right
now book you what are you talking about
also Ultra dismissive hand motion shut
your mouth hand motion nice
Advertiser products that did not exist
that are now wrapped up in brand safety
thirdparty verif ification the company
that was described about an hour
ago no longer
exists and I would argue pretty
aggressively no matter if you want to I
I I don't know the the the stat did you
say
telegram yeah five minutes ago when I
asked you why you're ranking below
Telegram and downloads and then you
started talking about scope and velocity
I did say telegram does anyone say
telegram no you're behind Telegram no no
I know I I I it I have to I have to
scrub up your numbers
um does anyone even talk about telegram
anymore yeah no I'm saying you guys were
behind them less downloads than them
you're worse than the people you're
making fun of yeah I got to scrub your
numbers okay let's scrub it up dub App
Store charts
free free apps let's go where you at
Telegram telegram number
x x number 63 we scrubed the numbers
Linda you're behind Southwest
Air you're behind peacock and impulse
brain training oh greatest app of all
time here right coming in at number 68
let's go we scrubbed the numbers we
scrubbed them they're good they're clean
um but that being said that when you put
in context
what has happened in the last 10 months
and specifically the last 12 weeks of
listening to our employees listening
listening to your employees you fired
all your employees you fired 80% of your
employees what are you talking about you
can't hear
them they're W they're walking away with
their box from their desk what are you
going to hear the great news is another
fact that was um
inaccurate uh uh in June actually did an
interview with one of your colleagues at
CNBC Sarah Eisen specific time and I
think August was that August 100 days oh
yeah I started in June it's all a blur
um uh because again the pace of
innovation is unlike anything oh what a
gem of an
excuse the next time I'm like oh I'm
late to pick up my daughter from school
it's the pace of
innovation so why I'm
late you could ever imagine uh think
about it it's exhilarating to the point
of intoxicating that's
why she's got bars though I'll give her
that she's like Mike Tyson there's no
one that can match me my style is
impetuous my defense is impregnable and
I'm just ferocious I want your heart I
want to eat his children praise be to
Allah and you get inspired and pushed by
Elon Musk to do the things that you
would never normally think were possible
you land on a day like today you show up
you tell them the mountain high of
accomplishments that were made in just
12 weeks she's going Michelle Obama when
they go low we go high and you don't
look back and compare yourself to a
legacy company that doesn't exist all
you're doing is comparing yourself what
are you talking about Linda I want to
get some of these stats so you mentioned
your it's been a day so I brought my car
you're welcome to I have my I was
supposed to was that blank just now hold
on got to go back I want to get some of
these stats so you mentioned your it's
been a day so I brought you're welcome
to I have I was supposed to I think that
might be a blank sheet of paper put an x
on it but I was watching the interview
and I didn't have time okay so one
question I have is what are the daily
active users that you have because that
is the metric that t was
using came over and you mentioned the
Sarah Eisen interview what are your
daily active users and then also you
told Sarah you were nearing
profitability how close are you yeah
well that's so exciting I'll get i'll
get back to your first question but
what's so bet she doesn't bet she does
not get back to that first question hey
I'll bet you a dollar Linda you only bet
a dollar I bet you a dollar you don't
answer the daily activ question but
let's see exciting is that um from an
operating cash flow perspective we're
just about Break Even so the um uh a
kind of other emotion that was painted
in the previous talk feel pretty good
about where we are and when I did the
other talk that you said was in August
um it was too soon I think it was about
five or six week in I couldn't have eyes
on uh even the rest of third quarter let
alone fourth quarter so um now that I
have uh uh immers myself in the business
and we H have a good set of eyes on what
is predictable and what's coming is that
it looks like in early 24 we be turning
a profit so that's exciting so so 90% of
the top 100 advertisers have returned to
the platform in the last 12 weeks
alone about 1,500 have returned so
whether it is uh uh uh small business or
BR big Brands right like AT&T Visa
Nissan all returning why are they
returning they are returning because of
the power and significance of the
platform the place that X has in this
world why so do you have a stat on daily
active yeah I'm going
to I love the interviewer smile they're
like uh you've been bullshitting for
five minutes now now do were you going
to tell me the number or
no oh now she picked up her phone what
happened to her blank sheet of paper
probably it it it 200 250 something like
that so the stat 200 or 250 million
daily active users that's less than when
Elon bought it I'm pretty sure leave his
facts no this was when musk took over
there were 237 million monetizable daily
so so listen to this one of the reasons
that um um I'm in the chair I'm in today
and in the chair I am at X and I do not
like green eggs and ham I do not like
them Sam I
Am So condescending by the way this
whole like one of the reasons I'm in
this chair and you're down there like
that's basically the vibe the energy
that she gives off um she asked you
simple question how many daily
activities you got don't give us this
speech about why I'm in the chair I'm in
is because I'm so great that's not an
answer to how many daily activ users you
have leading the company is because I
knew for the last decade and you knew
this part of my old remit was to oversee
not only the advertising revenue for the
company but to look after all of our
Enterprise relationships our I still say
our um the all of the nbcu Enterprise
relationships and Twitter was one of
them I specifically used Ed the name
Twitter by the way
purposefully and and uh that's when for
10 years and how I fell in love with the
platform because I knew first of all we
all knew the trajectory of where
broadcast cable uh television and usage
and consumption was growing yeah the
previous company I was at was going down
down down down down and so now I'm just
the reason I'm in the chairman is
because I oversee this what is she
talking about
but this
oh hang
on she doesn't have X installed on the
home screen of her
phone I see Facebook I see
Instagram I do not see X it's a black
icon where is it I don't see
it wow and also what kind of psychopath
it looks like she has a settings wheel
on her dock what kind of psychopath does
that to show your phone talking about
how great X is and then not have the app
installed this is why ah this is why
this is why I do what I do this is why I
do what I do aggressive
clap this is why I do what I do this is
why as the mayor of cringe City we live
for this moment where she thinks she's
mic dropping she thinks she's saying
this
really impressive important thing
and she's just embarrassing herself
that's news when you when I used to sit
in my office and watch you on television
it was the only what do some work why
were you at the office watching
television well I'd love to love to I'll
give you I'll give you almost like a
more personal
specific uh number which demon all right
another dollar bet I'm up $1 is this
going to be personal or specific I bet
it's neither rates part of the growth at
X if you take our communities
50,000 curated why we talking about
50,000 communities I thought it's going
to be personal and specific
Linda environments and conversations of
communities on X
okay the
the pause to just absolutely make up
whatever that wherever the hell she's
going just be like okay so i s 50,000
communities what the hell could I say
next numbers and time spent is up
dramatically just since June okay right
so where was the personal and specific
example Linda so hold on I want to Linda
we're running short on time so I got to
get we have so much to cover here so
where do you where do you want to go
okay I want to talk about your role
running the company and Elon Musk just
announced a new monthly fee for users
yep and my question for you is do you
want to start charging all users of X as
he said and how many users do you think
you will lose as a
result can you
repeat can you repeat you
repeat this reporter just broke news to
the CEO I'm pretty sure that that could
you repeat was a what the hell are you
talking about let me buy some timeon
musk announced you're moving to an
entirely subscription based service
Nothing free on about using X do you did
he say we were moving to it specifically
or is thinking about it he said that's
the plan yeah so did he yeah news to me
consult you before he announced that we
talk about everything okay defensive so
defensive gotta go back hold on did he
say we were moving to it specifically or
is thinking about it oh the sit back
like she just served her like this is uh
whatever Stomp the Yard and she's
just
her and then he said that's the plan
yeah so did he consult you before he
announced that cuz you're the CEO right
we talk about everything no eye contact
look to the crowd we talk about
everything did you guys hear that
everything is okay I'm in charge here
okay you don't cover product the all of
the product teams report to Elon Musk
and as a result of that there's been a
lot of anyone in this room can I can I
finish please wait L let me finish
please let me finish as a result of the
fact that the product team does not
report to you the product team at meta
reports to Mark Zuckerberg because the
product team does not report you there
has been speculation that you are in
more of a COO role or a sibo role a CEO
in name only role you know what's funny
is that we talk about that a lot at x uh
as you you do everybody asks you are you
really the CEO you guys talk about that
a lot know it's a very flat organization
and the teams are very empowered to
perform at their highest levels and
who's kidding
who I don't care what the structure is
at meta but who wouldn't
want Elon Musk sitting by their side
running Pro
I see a show of
hands I there may be a few show of hands
to get the cute Chuckles you're getting
honestly that's a good point uh Elon R
Elon is a
um a very very very accomplished
engineer and uh person capable building
things so I think it's totally right
you'd rather have him running a product
engineering organization not definitely
not this lady definitely not the ASMR
CEO I mean can you imagine her trying to
talk to an engineer like this lady's
asking for her number and of like hey
how many users do we have and she's
talking in circles about velocity of
change and Innovation and blah blah blah
and saying I'm going to I'll come back
to that like Engineers don't like that
[__] uh you know you can't just talk
circles around people who actually build
things you um you have to directly
answer their questions or directly give
clear concise
statements this lady is I mean the BS
detector is
like I mean if if if the uh car industry
wasn't questioned would we have the
electronic car industry I
mean uh pretty sure she just said
electronic cars
industry is that what you think Tesla
does it makes small electronic cars
instead of electric
cars you'll be hearing some of those
announcements in the next week week or
two but thank you so much everyone I got
to go I really appreciate Ito thank you
for making the time for us today let's
see how they ex oh the
snub no handshake no hug of no uh words
I really appro thank you for making the
time for us today stand up thank you and
walks by pretends like you don't exist
nice power
move okay um yeah I grade this and F
that is an F defensive insecure says
nothing of substance uh this is crazy to
me that this is the CEO of Twitter as it
will be called
um not inspiring I don't understand why
somebody would like this is like I think
when people think about Corporate
America or bureaucratic companies like
this to me is the nightmare somebody
like this rises in the ranks and becomes
CEO of one of the best tech company you
know one of the best technology products
in the world uh that's used by you know
whatever hundreds of millions of people
doesn't know the first thing about
technology or product or speaking
straight English um is just a handwavy
type of person that's really crazy to me
I got to see more okay this is what is
this I Googled her name and this was the
first picture that came
up you know maybe don't pose maybe don't
pose like Jesus on the cross for your uh
for your front page photo maybe don't
wear all red and dress like and pose
like Jesus on the cross uh does she
always talk like this I want to see some
of her old interviews okay let's see
what is
this Stephanie rule I accept your coid
19 challenge I'm still stuck mostly at
home and I'm doing okay she lost her
mind in that video um why is she
accepting the co 19
[Music]
challenge dancing and washing your hands
nothing more performative people
uploading videos of themselves
precautions this this is how we should
end the video just I just want this
uninterrupted for 25 seconds producer 25
seconds un interrupted of
this wow
unbelievable unbelievable okay yeah I
gray
um I gray that interview and f
um just comes across like a total
bullshitter um doesn't answer any
questions directly super defensive weird
ASMR voice and by the way her background
it's not like okay when Zuck does weird
interviews and it's like oh he looks
like a robot this guy's terrible okay
genius kid programmer turns out to not
be so media Savvy this lady's a media
exec she's 60 years old spent her whole
career 40 years working in the
television industry how is she so poor
at doing interviews or media that was
that's supposed to be what you're good
at if this is how you're like is this
what you're good at
because you're terrible um all right
well that is the end of Sean reacts
cring City hope you like this video if
you like these I'll do more of them
there's plenty of cringe out there
there's cringe everywhere to be honest
with you if you like these and you want
me to do more leave a comment on YouTube
saying cring
City our software is the worst have you
heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better